hey what's up this is John dallona with
Ramsey Network hope you're doing good
staying safe being smart
lights out gorilla radio all the things
right so here's we're talking about
today how to create a home how to create
a partnership that is not overrun by
anxiety and I want to mention a couple
of things that I haven't talked about
Jeff anxiety is not bad it's really a
good thing most of the time it lets us
know when we're disconnected it lets us
know when there are threats around the
corner it inspires us right you got a
big test tomorrow and you get that
anxiety you're gonna study it pushes you
forward right you're getting married
soon and you're anxious about it like
you get nervous
it inspires you right to go get some
premarital counseling to read some books
to have some good conversations about
what kind of life we want to build
together anxiety is not inherently a bad
thing it's when the alarms go off too
soon
too quick all the time and they become
the focus and drivers of our life that's
when we get anxiety issues or as the
Nerds call it anxiety disorders right
when it just takes over so what we're
gonna do today is we've talked about a
couple of quick things that you can do
to help
fireproof your house you're not gonna
ever do away with things out in you
don't want that and I don't want that
but we can create an ecosystem where the
alarms don't go off all the time
number one you take care of your mess
you take care of you you can't heal
anybody
you can't save anybody you can't change
anyone else's thoughts or behaviors you
can only change your own so deal with
your mess are you fully present are you
always trying to solve somebody else's
problems hey well you know you should be
doing is this or you know if you would
just stop or mmm have you exercised this
week boom that's just gas on the fire
gas on the fire the more you can walk
around your home on to firm feet knowing
that you have value that you are loved
that you're someone who reaches out and
loves other people that you've got
people in your life you can be
vulnerable with the more you help Co
regulate your house the more everybody
in your house has
opportunity to get more peaceful number
to make daily and weekly plans control
what you can control
we often say I don't know what
tomorrow's gonna look like we're in the
middle is pandemic right I don't know
what tomorrow's gonna look like I don't
know what next month is gonna look like
we were starting to say like oh buds
gone it's back dude it's super back
right
we don't know I can't control most of
today I can't control a lot of this week
and I for sure can control how I connect
with my spouse and plan for what the
next couple days are gonna look like and
remember that we speak in words but we
think in pictures and so when me and my
wife sit down and I say let's have a fun
weekend this weekend she's like that
sounds awesome let's put on the calendar
fun time this weekend fun time for me
might be getting in bed and going to
sleep at 7:30 p.m. now waking up til the
next day and just letting the kids run
amok upstairs I don't care what they do
and a fun time for her might be camping
hiking playing frisbee with the kids out
in the yard whatever that may be the
words we used were let's go have fun
together but our pictures were different
and so we both ended up disappointed at
the end of that week so it's important
when you're connecting when you're
making plans when you're controlling the
things that you can control that you
speak and think in pictures what is
today going to look like what is dinner
going to be how do you want after dinner
to look like tonight do you need a crazy
time some fun some running around do you
need intimacy time tonight do you want
to just chill and watch a movie you need
to take the kids while you go for a walk
what does that look like right number
three don't give advice to an anxious
person their prefrontal cortex is
offline the part of their brain that
thinks rationally that absorbs facts is
off they are running on cortisol
adrenaline and survival
they can't hear facts they can absorb
connection they can feel your presence
your eyesight
so many of us want to treat people like
broken machines and puzzles to solve
and that just furthers the gap between
an anxious person and the people who
love them choose to be with people don't
try to solve them number four keep
supporting the ecosystem what does that
mean that sounds all academic and nerdy
that means this you've gotta sleep
you've got to exercise you've got to eat
as healthy as you can you've got a hug
and love your kids you've got to turn
your screens off and go outside you
cannot constantly be scrolling the news
and picking partisan sides and yelling
at experts you're wrong but you're right
or whatever the thing may be a big part
of keeping the ecosystem going is making
sure the house is in order
making sure your heart and your spirit
and your mind is in order and you've got
to have a firm foundation to do that so
to recap you got to deal with your own
mess you got to make sure you believe
that you're a person of value that
you're okay number two you got to make
daily plans weekly plans and you've got
to Fink and speak in words number three
don't give advice to an anxious person
don't be over them don't try to fix them
be with them and number four keep
feeding the ecosystem take care of it
honor your body's honor your spirit
honor your minds this dr. John de Loney
do all the internet stuff clicks
subscribes send to your friends and
families here's another idea if you
think these videos are terrible send
them to people you don't like but make
sure they subscribe to this is dr. John
Delaney peace out have a good week
take care